hello and happy international chess day
chess fans i'm sam copeland a national
master on the content team here at
chess.com
and i'm here today to show you an
incredible computer chess game
what would happen if you combined the
positional skills of anatoly karpov
with the raw tactical and calculation
ability of gary kasparov that is
effectively the question that the
developers of stockfish knew
the new strongest chess engine on the
planet
are trying to answer they've taken a
neural network the technology that
powers
alpha zero and lila chess zero and gives
them great positional evaluations
and integrated it into stock fish the
traditional chess
engine that looks at a hundred million
positions per second
this new engine is estimated to be at
least 30 elo stronger than
any engine on record and it debuts today
in the chess.com computer chess
championship
with a 200 game match against leela
chessero followed by another 200 game
match against the most recent version
of stockfish we're going to look at a
warm-up game
played against another strong neural
network engine stoofles
played just three days ago stockfish new
opens the game with e4
and stuffless elects to respond with the
sicilian defense and in particular the
dragon variation
of the sicilian defense this opening is
always sharp
always exciting so it's great to see it
here in this battle between these chess
engines now we're going to see the
engines follow theory for a while it's
hard to say whether this is
knowing or unknowing from the engines
but
we are going to see a novelty on move 13
from stuffless as
after a3 instead of the played pawn to
a5
stuffless innovates with a move never
before seen in the chess.com database
with pawn to b4 a pawn sacrifice
this is a very very dangerous pawn
sacrifice as you're going to see in the
coming lines
i think almost any human when faced with
this novelty
over the board would collapse in very
short order
after pawn to b4 you've got to accept
the sacrifice pawn or things are getting
wrecked anyway and you gain no material
so pawn takes on b4 and now a5
trying to open the a file now stockfish
new is not going to open the a file
voluntarily so pawn to b5 trying to keep
things closed
and stooplus insists pawn to a4
if bishop takes a4 you do have an idea
to try
and solidify everything but you don't
have enough time to do it
queen to a5 here and after pawn to b3
e5 simply wins the game this move is
terribly terribly anti-positional you
never want to play this move in the
dragon and make your bishop bad
and make this d5 square a tremendous
weakness
but here you're just pushing the bishop
away from the knight
white loses the knight on c3 and loses
the game very quickly
so after a4 we get bishop a2 trying to
keep things closed
and stoofless insists again with another
pawn sacrifice
pawn to a3 now after pawn to a3
it is possible to take but very very
detailed analysis
seems to show that white would be busted
after capturing on a3
here the move is queen to a5 putting
pressure here and here
after king b2 defending both of those
weak points
rook to a8 puts more pressure on a3
and pawn to a4 seems like it defends
everything
but then bishop takes b5
boom this is a tremendous
move now of course you have two captures
here
first let's look at knight takes b5 this
capture
is relatively easy to refute you can now
take on a4 here you're hitting the
knight and you're hitting the bishop so
the only move to defend both
is knight back to c3 queen check
king back and now you just need to
remove this knight and you can win
on a2 and give checkmate so here e5
pushing the bishop around
and then rook to c8 will win the game
now the harder move to refute after
bishop takes b5
is the capture with the pawn a takes b5
but here we have queen b4 check king
back to a1
and now rook to c8 and in this position
it turns out that there's just nothing
productive for white to do
and in particular there's no good way to
make use
of the heavy pieces for example you
would like
to play rook to b1 attacking the queen
and pushing her back
but this shows exactly why you couldn't
move that rook and introduce your pieces
rook takes a to check and wins
if the king takes you simply get mated
on the a file and if the knight takes we
see that we did need that rook on d1
the queen is now hanging on d2
very very nice stuff of course that's
only a sample of the possible lines
but as a result of lines like that we do
see stockfish new
decline to accept this sacrifice pawn
here on a3
instead i think we see the first
brilliant move
from stockfish new rook h e1
stockfish new simply ignores everything
that is going on in the queen side takes
the one piece
the rook on h1 that is not contributing
and brings it to the center of the board
now it seems like things are going to
get wrecked on the queen side and we do
see the destruction
of the white pawn protection around the
king but after the king takes
what turns out to matter is the pressure
on the centrophiles
that white has centralization is still
important
and it turns out that the bishop is able
to simply slide over to b3
and cover the white king and the white
king is actually totally safe
as it turns out safer than the black
king
so this rook he1 move very calm very
collected
proves to be the turning point in the
game
so now we see rook to b8 pawn to e5
if you take here the rook takes here no
fear
the bishop on g7 is allowed a discovery
but after a move like 98 the rook simply
slides over there's huge pressure on the
d
file and again the white king is totally
safe and the rook is
also helping defend this pawn on b5 so
after e5
stoopless plays knight back to e8
there's a trait on d6
there's a trade on g7 queen d4 check
king g8
now bishop b3 again this bishop is just
a beautiful defender of the white king
now bishop takes b5 and now knight d5
and this is a critical moment in the
game there is huge pressure here
on this pawn on e7 and of course if that
pawn goes
there's also a tremendous attack against
the black king
how does black defend that pawn in e7 as
it turns out there's not
any really good way to defend that pawn
if knight f5
then white is able to win a pawn with
knight takes e7
and after knight takes trading queens
removes the defender
of the knight and now white should win
this game
relatively comfortably thanks to the
extra pawn and the pressure
on f7 so after knight to d5
we see rook e8 and now we need another
brilliant move
we have rook takes e7
boom another great move now
after rook takes e7 which is forced in
this position
you could simplify to an end game knight
takes and then take on d6
you have one extra pawn in this end game
are you
able to win from here probably best for
black
is to keep the queens on and this is
very close
maybe it's winning for white maybe not
instead
we see stockfish new now try knight to
f6
choosing to remain a rook down to
continue the attack
now after knight to f6 check we see king
f8 you pick up a pawn on h7 and after
the king moves over
e8 is the same the knight returns to f6
and pushes the king
back to f8 in this position knight d5
is now the dangerous continuation of the
attack there's the idea of queen h8 mate
and obviously the rook is also under
attack you can take on e7 and then maybe
pick up on d6 and now you would have two
extra pawns so it's no longer a question
of if the end game would be winning
it will be easily easily won so
after knight to d5 the best defense as
played by
black is pawn to f6 cutting off this
diagonal so that the queen cannot
deliver mate
on h8 now the queen takes on f6 check
but the sacrifice
of the pawn now allows black to play
knight to f7
covering the czechs and this knight as
knights often are when they're placed
right in front of the king
is an amazing defender it covers all of
the dangerous
uh squares where white could give check
from the queen
so here knight to f4 this is a great
move
of course there's a sacrifice here queen
takes down here on d1 as possible
but knight takes g6 is made in two the
king can run in either direction
but after king to g8 there is a
beautiful mate here
with queen to h8 and the knight on f7 is
uh is pinned by the bishop on b3
and if you move over to e8 we simply
have a queen and helper mate
with the queen stepping directly in
front of the king
so backing up here after knight to f4
the only defensive try
for the engine is to block on the d file
and we now see bishop to d7
in this position stockfish new plays
another
really truly brilliant move a move that
i think
almost no human could find so
in this position what you would like to
play is knight takes g6 check
but after king to e8 trading down on e7
is not necessarily going to win the game
easily
it will remain very very complicated so
after king to e8 what you want to do is
play queen to g7
which is almost game over the idea of
queen to f8
would crush black except for rook takes
b3
check and now if you take back with the
pawn which is a mistake
rook to e2 check and there's no way to
avoid
checks introducing the queen or the
bishop and suddenly black has
winning counter play therefore
in the position after bishop d7 instead
of taking on g6
stockfish new plays the brilliant
rook to d2 this is a tremendous
prophylactic move
that simply stops the idea of rook takes
b3
and rook down to e2 with check that
check is now covered
and the idea is simply to go back to
this idea knight takes g6
check king e8 queen g7 and mate is
simply forced
as it turns out there's really nothing
that these pieces can do
to stop this idea so
the only way to fight on is now rook
takes
b3 check getting rid of this monstrous
bishop
on b3 now c takes b3
and again you must defend very carefully
the idea of taking here and then taking
on e7
is a monstrous threat so you must pull
back rook to e8
trading the queens off right now knight
takes g6
first and then after the king moves over
you trade the queens and the rook is
able to recapture that's why
the rook had to go to e8 so it could
recapture and not the knight
so that d7 would be defended now
in this position white has four pawns
for the piece is this an in-game win
now stockfish is evaluating this as
about plus one
which can be on the border between a win
and a draw
but i really think that this is simply a
winning endgame
you have a past b pawn over here and
three past pawns on this side of the
board
in time as you slowly position your
pieces you're going to push forward on
both wings
and i don't think that any defense from
black is going to save the game
so we see relatively slow patient
maneuvering play
for a while the rooks are going to get
traded on the d-file which is relatively
natural
and now white is slowly going to make
progress
the key is to improve your knight and
improve your kink
and eventually push the pawns only when
you feel like you have control over the
position
now to make progress we're going to see
stockfish new start swinging the king
over to the king side after placing the
knight on a really good square here on
d4
and then it's time to start pushing the
queen side pawns
you can't really make progress with just
the pawn on the b-file
but these pawns together support each
other and they're able to push
on the king side eventually the b-pawn
is going to be used as a decoy
on the queen side and you'll be willing
to sacrifice it
in order to make progress on the king
side which is what happens
right now after the knight takes on b6
these pieces are about as distant from
the action as possible it doesn't matter
too much for the bishop
which is a long range piece but it
definitely matters for the knight
the pawns are rolling on the king side
and all there are
although there are some mines that white
needs to avoid stepping on here
it is a winning position this pawn now
pushes forward all the way to h7
and in this position black has no
ability to really attack any of the
pawns
or to thoroughly blockade them this
knight is trying to stay here to keep
a dark square blockade going but
uh in this position if it ever actually
goes to f6
then you simply sacrifice one of the
pawns and you take here you're up two
pawns and you win
in just a couple of moves so after king
g5 we see bishop c8 and a nice maneuver
here
from stockfish new the knight is going
to e7
no way to stop it and after it goes to
e7 it sacrifices itself
to push this pawn forward again knight
f6 simply allows you to sacrifice
and win the knight on f6 so knight takes
e7
pawn to f6 check king back to h8
and in this position you need to be
careful one more time
if you take the knight then drawing by
force is bishop to e8
king f6 and bishop takes g6 a nice
sacrifice
to force stalemate therefore after king
h8 here
you simply push forward with f7 and
there's no way to stop promotion
you can try to put the king on g7 to
cover both promotion squares but
if one piece is defending two things
then usually it's not really defending
both of them
you simply sacrifice the queen here and
then you make a queen over here
and after knight to g8 there's no kind
of blockade or anything because
queen f7 and you have mate coming over
here
therefore after f7 the knight sacrificed
itself and after king takes we simply
get a queen next move and after bishop
c8
that queen gave checkmate on the board
which did conclude this brilliant game
again if you want to see more games
where stockfish new is taking on leela
chess zero
and where stockfish new is taking on the
most recent versions of stockfish
simply head over to chess.com ccc
to see it in action